hey guys Pete here I usually wait a week
or two between these spoiler updates for
Game of Thrones but just as I was
finishing my video yesterday crazy new
stuff started coming out this video will
be shorter than the other one but I
thought I should make a part 2 right
away because this news is big like I
mentioned in all my other set leaked
videos this will contain spoilers about
the major characters and their
storylines if you don't want to know
those things please stop watching now if
you do like production spoilers then
keep watching and stick around to the
end to learn about the giveaway I'm
doing for my subscribers now let's get
right into it as a quick disclaimer all
of the info and images I share in these
videos come from reputable sources on
the Internet I'm just compiling it all
together for you guys none of this stuff
is secret exclusive or not already
posted on media and news sites the
information about Gendry and the
warhammer came directly from those
sources and I just take it at face value
it's not my opinion that it was Joe
Dempsey in the scene it came from lo
siete ray knows who posted the actual
footage so right as I was finishing the
video with all the news coming out of
the set locations in Spain a photo
emerged on Instagram and then made its
way to read it it's a grainy image taken
from a great distance but it shows
Damaris and John filming a scene
together it confirms that the mother of
dragons will be treating with the king
in the north at what looks like
Dragonstone at some point in season 7
when I saw this I was expecting to see
more high quality images come out today
from the Spanish website and they
arrived just a little while ago on top
of that we also got a video which shows
Jon Snow descending the staircase with
Damaris waiting at the bottom as he
approaches she turns in the to have a
conversation Jon's added a cloak to his
stark armor and Dany is dressed in a
dark color it's hard to make out any
details since the video is shot from
such a far way away and the weather also
seems windy which makes the focus a
little less than optimal despite the
quality and the lack of details it's
still incredible to see Jon approach
Daenerys there will be plenty of time to
speculate in the comments about what is
actually going on in the scene and I'm
sure we will get more photos from the
set as this
shooting will be continuing all week
plus they have a couple other locations
that they're getting ready to so next
weekend's update will have all kinds of
new stuff on top of this there was also
a picture that appears to show a red
priestess she was spotted by an Eagle
Eye fans since the original news
organization that posted the photo made
no mention of her it's hard to see the
actresses face but Watchers on the wall
say that their sources confirm that
season six is Kim bara the high
priestess from the red temple of
volantis will not appear in season seven
who would the red this red priestess be
then it seems like it almost has to be
Melisandre but that would bring up a lot
of questions first tell me if you think
it's her in the comments then let's talk
about how she would end up at the same
location where these two are meeting
Davos is there and he has made his
position clear when it comes to
Melisandre Jon backed him up completely
on this and sent her away but other than
Thoreau's and a couple really
insignificant characters we really don't
have any major characters who are
associated with the the red God so I am
really just at a loss as to who else it
might be now I know someone's gonna get
technical and say that he sent her south
and that's not really going against his
words since they are in the north but
that wouldn't explain how she ends up in
these pictures tyrion obviously used kim
bara
and marine as a way to spread the good
word about Queen Daenerys but would the
Queen herself be so easy to get on board
I mean she was gone at the time I'm not
saying I don't expect Melisandre to play
a key role in relation to the war for
the dawn I just think it's interesting
to speculate about how she would have
worked her way back in so that's pretty
much it it's definitely a shorter video
but I thought you guys would like to see
these spoilers and get the images of
this Danni and John stuff right away
I pulled stills from the original video
because the photographer who took it
likely uploaded the video as well so I
don't want to get a plain match problem
or have the video removed I'll probably
do what I did with the Gendry video edit
it and just post a snippet of it on my
Twitter and Instagram accounts with you
know proper credit to the guy who
actually took the images you can find
links to follow me
Twitter and Instagram in the description
of this video and you can also find them
on my main channel page let me know how
you guys think all this stuff is going
to play out what's your favorite leak so
far can you even decide at this point do
you think it's Melisandre and if so who
brought her back into the fold please
like the video if you want to see more
like it subscribe to my channel and
comment to be entered in the giveaway
when I hit 18,000 subscribers I'll be
picking one comment at random and
sending that subscriber a copy of the
night of the 7 kingdoms by Georgia arm
art it's the collection of his three
duncan egg stories that have been
released so far you can go watch my
other season 7 videos to comment on
those and that would increase your
chances at winning if you haven't
watched part one of the mega spoiler
report you should definitely check that
out for a whole lot more information
about these same shooting locations that
i talked about today thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon